every great moment in our history began
with a dream
each bold leap forward was achieved by
those willing to do anything to attain
it you're not Alec Ryder my father's
dead he made me his successor Alec is
dead system has stabilized I'm
establishing a connection
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we can talk more later sure we're being
steered into their ship just tell me
what you want I won't explain who
surprise is this anyway
maybe that's the surprise even on your
back you keep me on my toes let's
reenact how we met
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
all right for real
listen leaves make Baldwin Shepard that
we can do all right all right here we go
let's make Baldwin writer oh not Shep
mom Anna it's gonna be weird I know uh
customized parents can belt wouldn't be
female uh I'm sure I already picked
well actually we can probably go back
huh I don't know if this is actually a
good idea just kind of curious sure what
it's like it's like Baldwin's a sister
okay okay yeah she's the one who went to
Andromeda it's part of the lore oh yeah
yeah she was in she was in sleep okay
okay there we go
because you can make both twins so we
can technically make a Baldwin male
that's true ahead right but you can you
can customize those presets oh here we
go
it's because I have to do this it's been
a while you know I try and play it at
least once every couple months
how about that skin tone uh Oh pasty
alright for sure she's been in cryo
sleep she hasn't seen the Sun really
long time good five hundred years
sure yes I rest cheeks she just have
something in common with him Oh like the
guy yeah cheekbone with no if she kite
raise it up all right yep it's okay it's
okay nice long chin
can I turn you can you rotate her there
we go there we go okay yeah now we're
talking I don't to make it like too
ridiculous I feel like it's not letting
you get to yeah it was better than this
it's okay it's it's decently ridiculous
but it's much fun of the sliders that
want that's pretty good though that you
could almost mistake that for a Baldwin
ship or maybe maybe I think the lips are
too thick kinda looks like a watch mask
yeah yeah I can see that real tiny nose
yeah oh now I'm getting like a Michael
Jackson vibe oh my gosh I am too
oh that's what we're doing that's not
bad I like that one a lot actually I
mean I'm a little disappointed there's
no balding option like there's like the
shave but nothing bald yeah alright I
think the winner is this the emo one
that we passed yeah that one's pretty
good yes one that one's pretty good
all right I like that one something
about the way the hair sticks up
complements the job yeah hair color I
think this is where you could get a
little bit more ridiculous
and the makeup the makeup is actually
where you can get really ridiculous uh
Baldwin had red hair Baldwin did have
red hair had blond hair and then he had
red hair probably went through some
changes Baldwin did go through some
changes it's not bad I kind of like that
orangey one yeah it's about that works
for me
eyes oh my gosh inner color outer color
oh geez
I know can't make it more dead not as
dead as I want him to be yeah okay
all right makeup eyeshadow oh okay all
right
turn up the opacity today that's a weird
one and then when you make it like a
dark red it kind of just looks like
there's something wrong like yeah it
doesn't look like it's like actually on
her it just looks like it's yeah and
it's like on her eyelashes too like it
looks like I don't know I'll leave it at
that
sure why not oh we can do this scaly one
I got the weird scales
it's weird I don't like this at all it's
like skin colored too
they're going for like a I guess they're
trying to do like what sci-fi makeup
look like but but they're not doing it
very well yeah I'm just like that's not
appealing it just looks like I don't
know burned or something like that but
we'll leave it like that yeah someone
took like a hot and mesh wire like oh
yeah Oh scars okay now you're talking
know what that's like the see that's the
that's the hot metal why are they jammed
I see I almost want to get rid of the
eye I can get rid of it it's honestly I
think it's a bit much it's a little bit
more manager I want to get rid of the
lip thing though get rid of the lip
thing too or you could try different we
enjoyed it yeah maybe try different kind
whoa that okay we found it good work
good work everyone
that's crazy how do you put that on
every day okay customized twin and this
is Baldwin yeah we got a review all
right uh I just custom again also I like
this symbol up here like what does that
that's custom face what is that supposed
to be just like a face with lines
weird anyway like a Baldwin Shepherd was
pretty dang but he looked old too he was
white
he looked old yeah very pasty but the
skin tones to it needs to be a little
bit like pastier yeah I feel like that
one's pretty pasty this one yeah that
one one more to the left
like this one maybe yeah let's go with
that one
he had kind of ridiculous eyebrows
didn't need he did I can pull up a photo
oh yeah that'll probably let's get that
yeah let's get a picture of the old
Baldwin that's like that's like the
rougher more experienced Baldwin
Shepherd you know he's he's seen some
he's seen some [ __ ] I mean Baldwin's
changed his appearance before so we can
try and kind of match it but it's true
he's got a oh yeah so his eyebrows work
just crazy they were non-existent okay I
don't do that maybe when we go to hair
color we can make it like well I don't
think we can we'll see well this nose
was pretty wide that's as wide as I can
get it alright that's that's yep that
was high kind of low - looking at that
picture I feel like it was more that
just his mouth was higher I don't know
oh I can I can see I can put his mouth
higher yeah can you make a chin more
like flat at the bottom uh try flat at
the bottom okay
hair style now let's see I bet they
won't have I'm pretty sure it's just the
same haircuts yeah what if let me run
this by you what if this cryosleep has
done wonders to his hair and you know he
goes in looking like the old Baldwin
comes out and he comes out pretty good I
was gonna say that was a Macklemore
haircut because Baldwin Shepard seems
like the kind of guy who thinks -
Macklemore haircuts still cool that
could work too did I pass that one I
think that's a really on that one's
pretty early oh that's like the first
one huh now I keep going no surly yeah
there it is I could see that yeah I see
either this one or the long-haired one I
kinda like the long heroin though I
think it was 15 I think I like the long
luscious he's got he's got some nice red
hair oh yeah they do right
can we can make this happen I kinda want
to keep those that color
no his was like a red like a dark red I
think right yeah this was like red yeah
all right I kind of like that yeah what
color eyes does he have it's a little
Baldwin like you can't adjust the eyes
that much there's not like AI types
they're all the same kind of eyes man
just kind of a bummer but we'll make do
with what we have I don't know there
yeah that's okay you can't get weird
with this one as much as you want but
what we can get weird with is the scar
that's true we he didn't really have a
scar I have previously so we can kind of
give him a big fat scar right over his
face yeah make it nice and off yes
matches his hair the new Baldwin Shepard
the Baldwin Shepard the bolt this is
probably like Baldwin's son I'd say oh
there you go
Baldwin jr. there's no tattoos no
vetoing the tattoos all right there you
go that's um Baldwin's kids I think it's
what we're gonna Bowl her name I how
about we just named her be be there you
go right or do you Ryder okay with that
all right there we go
all right those are the Baldwin twins
although they're going by Ryder cuz they
don't want to be associated with their
dad which it's probably for the best
often baby went to a whole new galaxy
just to just get away from him yeah they
think it's cuz the Reapers no it's not
cuz the Reapers hey I want to be
associated with their dad anyway and if
Baldwin was my dad I'd probably hightail
it out of the Milky Way too
absolutely anyway thanks for sticking
around for those of you who are watching
this most of the most people watching
his probably don't get this no they
don't but this is for you this is for
those five people that got it and we
hope you enjoyed it and have a wonderful
wonderful Sunday evening